hello uh hello people watching this
hopefully we'll see you in the comments
hello
go ahead and uh introduce ourselves um
i am matthew gatos i am the producer and
editor
um journey of the microcosmos
[Music]
whoever wants to go next the bookie
oh sure um i'm devoki and i am the
writer for our journey to the
microcosmos
and this is james i'm the guy behind the
microscope
and that was paula our communications
coordinator that you saw there
uh in the corner there for a second uh
and she's the one
arranging all of this making sure that
we're able to do what we're doing right
now
uh so thank her thank you paula um
but hank will be joining us very soon
and yeah
we are here today to celebrate 500 000
subscribers
which includes all of you watching this
uh so we're gonna answer some questions
from the chat we're gonna
answer some questions that we asked for
on social media and other places and
then we're also
just gonna you know talk about the
channel a bit talk about who we are what
we do
uh and obviously we're gonna be looking
at some live microscopy
over there on the side uh from james um
yeah i just yeah i'll put some
stationary thing over there so we can
just watch something and i can
i can see you guys at the same time are
you trying to chase ms center
yeah yeah but it's not going really good
you know because i have to look at you
and interact with you and then i have to
take a
pencil here which is rather
fast you know it's a little different
from your normal
day of microscopy yeah i don't have to
speak
like i speak with my cat sometimes but i
made like a
little dust cover for my cats no sorry
for my microscope but
um then i put a shaggy carpet on the
dust cover and they are just sleeping
above my microscope so when i'm just
doing microscopy i'm just like petting
them at the same time
so living the life
yeah how many hours a day
james are you at your microscope
like it depends sometimes like
especially when i collected some new
samples from interesting places like
i spent maybe like 12 hours
a day and i just keep recording keep
just
checking things and when i stop
using the microscope i just go back to
the couch and i have a bunch of books
over there and my books they don't
sit on the shelf they have to be next to
me because like
i have to go through them all of them
every day
and then i like try to identify what i'm
finding
what i was finding and then i have to
you know like
um check some details of the cell so
it's basically this is my whole life i'm
doing microscopy then i'm doing some
micro stuff and then i'm
you know preparing some videos of the
microbes and
that's it nice
yeah i'd say uh that's a good rundown of
james's average day my average day is
not 12 hours spent
working on microcosmos uh hello to all
the people in the chat who are joining
uh hank will be here he's on his way
uh so if you're wondering who we are
again we are the team
behind uh the videos that you don't hear
from or see
and yeah i my average day on microcosmos
is much more of uh
organizing the behind the scenes uh
making sure we're staying on schedule
and also editing the videos which
involves
you know sound design picking the music
out we have
we are very lucky to have andrew wong's
music to use he created i think around
21 original tracks
now for us to use on journey the
microcosmos
and it is uh amazing to have all of
those available to use
and so yeah that's my average week
working on a microcosm
video is doing the actual editing making
sure the production
stuff is all on schedule and then also
uh
yeah making sure that the uh the sound
design and the tone of the videos
stays consistent
what we're supposed to be doing yeah
yeah so
my my average day or week i guess of
microcosmos
involves basically taking in what
james's footage
shows us which is a lot of fun basically
just opening up the folder and seeing
like what cool new things and
sometimes just jotting down like a very
visceral like whoa this clip is super
weird kind of thing just like as a note
for
um for things that we're gonna like put
in the episode
and then um going through a lot of
papers some
old some new and just figuring out uh
yeah what we're gonna be talking about
and learning about
together yeah that's great
yeah i think hank is about to join us so
uh he can he can add his uh two cents to
his microcosmos worked
um i think everyone knows obviously hank
green narrator of the show
um and what are we looking at right
there uh james
um i'm just checking this really
chilling paramecium bursaria it's not
moving
too much let's say so i kind of like it
it's perfect for the live stream so what
you
what you see there like can you see
these
little fuzzy things around the cell
yeah they are cilia so it's just now
it's filtering the water
and it's just pulling all them
yeah because if i look at the live
stream and
try to follow the microorganisms this is
what happens
i have to look at here uh yeah so just
basically filtering
bacteria and eating what it gets and
there are some small ciliates swimming
around
yeah and hank is here hey hank i am
hello
good to see all of you um i'm hank green
i'm host of turning to the microcosm
sorry i'm late i got my schedule mixed
up
but i ran back from my taco place and
i'm here
oh now i'm just imagining somebody like
driving by seeing you sprint with a taco
in your hands
uh but yes for those joining us we are
here to celebrate the 500 000
subscribers that we've hit
uh somewhat recently uh and again thank
all of you
for that um and yeah we are here this is
the whole team
pretty much we have other people that i
feel like i do want to mention that have
helped
throughout the growth of the channel uh
we have
uh mark olson who did our whole visual
art design for the entire channel
uh helped us you know create a logo and
fonts
and the overall aesthetic of the channel
from everything from the intro screens
to the end screens to the channel design
and
yeah that was a very important step
early on in the process to have that
look defined uh obviously we have andrew
wong's music
which is amazing i talked about a little
bit earlier um we have paula who is
running this whole
show right now and making sure that we
are able to be seen
by you people right now um yeah
trying to think i'm probably forgetting
some people along the way there's
obviously a lot of people complexly who
make
everything work um but yeah uh
hey do you want to talk a little bit
about uh we talked a little bit about
our experiences
on a sort of weekly regular basis of the
things we do
um do you want to talk about sort of
what it's like recording
hosting um cosmos yeah i
um i usually get a
a script probably two scripts at a time
and then
uh do a little read through to make sure
i know how to pronounce everything
um sometimes i don't do that and i like
run into a word and then matt gets to
listen to me
curse for uh four or five minutes while
i try and look up how to pronounce
euglena or something and uh and then
if i fail then i will
uh i'll text james on whatsapp and be
like help me
um or i will tweet sometimes i'll be
like hey does anybody
anybody in the world know how to
pronounce this microorganism because
sometimes like
i kind of get the feeling that no one
does uh they're like
voldemort you know don't say the names
yeah i had to learn early on that there
was times where like
hank would say something in an audio
track and i it sounded either weird to
me or new to me in a way that i i wasn't
sure
so i would email james and be like is
this the way that you should say this
and james would just be like well no one
has ever really said it out loud in any
sort of public way
so yeah sure so here we are
a youtube channel defining the
pronunciation
of micro microorganisms so sorry to the
people who are very very into latin
or greek and stuff right sometimes
because people are like
no the latin root of this thing is this
and i'm like
i need to take a greek class yeah yeah i
got today like one semester of greek
wow
that's the shag carpet the cats sit on
yeah my cats are sleeping on
my
[Laughter]
while you have the camera turned there
some people in the chat were actually
asking if you can show
yeah the microscope situation uh sorry
can you say it again
oh yeah uh some people in the chat were
just wondering if you could turn you the
camera to show us the microscope
like you were just kind of doing but
like show us the whole setup
yeah microscope and we have a rather
primitive
way of recording right now so this is on
a tripod
and and the camera just looks into the
into the viewfinder
is it connected or is it just looking in
there this is no
this is not connected it's outside
see it's this is my cat
oh hello
so yeah they're on my microscope
like literally and they just put their
hats down
and i'm just like you know petting them
and i'm just
taking my microscope so yeah
what are you doing dad just looking at
my other pets
i've got i've got one cat and about 400
million
milliamp
i like that you have a cat tower with a
microscope attachment
yeah that's what that is yeah
um and the process of recording an
episode is is generally
like you know i've got i've got my
microphone here it's a very different
sort of thing i turn my mic way up and
then i talk very quiet
and then now i'm journeying to the micro
cosmos hank
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we have
gotten 500 000 subscribers
and there's actually a question about
that uh hank somebody asked
uh how do you manage to be so calm when
narrating
uh we all know of you as this like
excited extroverted person and not an
asmr narrator
seriously your narration is so calming i
love it you're awesome
said jimmy dean i don't think it's the
famous
thank you thank you sausage um
yeah it's it i don't know like when i
when i first
saw james's work and i was thinking
about what kind of show this would be
you know i was like people are starting
to spend time
on youtube and not and like maybe a lot
of youtube is very
frenetic and like keep like capture and
hold and
what if there was a way to to keep
people's attention without
um giving them uh you know 500 megabytes
of
information every second the way that
that we
kind of do uh at our other things um and
so like i
like i am a i am definitely a goofy
frenetic person in real life
a lot of the time but i'm also sometimes
quite sleepy
and um but but i'm also but like the
main thing is that like i
am what the heck is that what was that
thing
[Applause]
oh hey is that some conjugation
happening
but it i think it's gonna go wrong
i think it's not gonna work out for them
uh they don't look like this normally
like um they they usually come
side by side you know but these were
like
it's like a spiderman kiss you know
the spiderman kisses the the most polite
possible way of saying that
no what are you guys doing
maybe it was a small division because i
can't oh they broke apart oh
wait yeah have they figured out nope
all right yeah good try you guys yeah
because i
don't know much harder to record it's a
conjugation
so they're trying it again now oh james
is
james's footage of this is a little bit
before hours
yeah the feed is a little bit delayed so
we're seeing about 10 seconds
after he is seeing something yeah
i make another grow of it look we look
we want to exchange genetic material but
it's hard
i know man dating's never easy
oh we're gonna try and squeeze it okay
get myself stuck in the wall
do a bunch of spinning where'd you go
are you gonna fight do they do they have
some kind of like chemical signal that
they're sending to each other so they
find each other
uh yeah like for conjugation there are
like different types
of um mating types they're called mating
types
so let's say this is type one and this
one is type two
so one of them releases some pheromones
and it's just like it pulls the other
type
towards it and they they basically kiss
and then they exchange genetic material
yeah seems like they might be given up
now though yeah yeah
it's like if they if they want it
they'll get it
they'll find it uh i wanted to ask uh
along these lines oh sorry i wasn't i
wasn't done answering
i will continue the answer and and so
i thought what would it be like and so i
started to try and record
like chill in like chill ways and i was
what do i sound like in that
and how do people do it and and so i did
some research on how people do it and
like
you gotta turn your mic up so you can
talk a lot quieter
which is and i don't know i it was like
so like that the main thing is that like
i
i see myself as a host as an entertainer
and so like i like to
try out different ways of communicating
and uh and hopefully
i get i get better at each of them as i
flex the muscle
and um and it's really fun it's so fun
because like
not it's it's not just chill it's also
sort of like
like the voice of microcosmos is chill
but also like just
bliss like a little bit blissed out it's
like i'm really happy about this
um and i did always sort of imagine you
know there's a certain like
mental state that some people might be
in when they're watching microcosmos
um and uh not not like
guaranteed or anything i think that you
can watch it in all kinds of mental
states but i think that's sort of like a
very chill
blissed out vibe uh and is also sort of
like what we're going with
for the with the music and i think it's
reflected in
um you know these images that are
i i think that we can look at them and
without that context
it can seem a little almost
uh you know banal or boring um
but but if you sort of like put it in
that context it like suddenly
it's that um it's like cosmos but
but just like more euphoric
kind of yeah and it came together
like pretty quickly from idea to
production it was just one of like one
of those things i remember
you had this idea and when it was
presented to me
i was immediately like oh yes i know
exactly what that like
ten word description yes chill beats
calm narration
slow paced editing i got this let's go
yeah
yeah um
oh sorry sorry continuously okay i was
just gonna say it's uh
it uh is seeing the uh the
you know as we've gotten as james has
gotten new equipment just like that has
affected
how cool it is to look at and watch um
and this microscope is just so pleasant
to narrate to and to and to watch the
content
we have some more news about it i think
we don't know when we're going to
announce it but
we have some more sprites about the
microscopy and the equipments
so it's going to be getting right oh
yeah there's
it's it's like one of those things like
whenever james is talking about cool
microscope
parts and things he's upgrading i'm like
that sounds great when we make a video
about it he's like well
it arrives in eight weeks so by the time
we make videos
yeah so it's sort of one of those things
it's hard to like let you guys out there
watching know that like we have
cool stuff coming you'll see it in four
months
yeah yeah yeah
yeah we have like james has a huge
backlog of footage
uh but now it's like some of it feels
less usable because our current footage
is so much prettier than
the older stuff yeah i think like my
40 terabytes footage isn't
not working right now you know it's just
like sitting on some hard disks
over or over there it's like i mean you
know
yeah i would feel really bad if just
you know we show something else than the
the ic microscopy because it looks
so pretty and i'm also worried
because you know i don't want that to
say like okay
james you have better footage than this
come on you can do better than this and
i need to edit this now
so i wouldn't i wouldn't worry about
that i mean the main thing is like if
there are things that oh hello little
friend if there
are things that we
um i guess can't
can't like we you have footage of it
that's like it's a difficult thing to
capture
or rare to see that we would we could
still
you know use some of your backlog
footage if if we needed extra footage of
something
uh unique or surprising um
or even if it was like we just don't
have an enough footage of this
particular organism it's a nice little
happy face
thing yeah what is this
friend
[Music]
so but it has some um
barium crystals yeah
see them on the
a lot of people are asking about the
kickstarter microscope in the comments
and about sort of the the process the of
that the progress
on that and also uh basically like
what's the plan for the microscope going
forward
hank do you want to handle that question
sure yeah um
i so so one of the one of the things
that is really exciting about
having sort of a standard microscope for
people who are in our audience is
one you know i i will have the same
microscope so that's
that's cool and i i will you know i
it's funny you know i like the i think
the most interesting thing to look at
like that has the most depth is like
living stuff
but there's also all kinds of stuff i
can put under the microscope and be like
oh
and just like shove my phone under there
and be like holy crap
um and i think i think it could be
really cool actually
did we talk about this to do an episode
where we put
like like first generation iphone
through current iphone under the
microscope to see how
the pixels themselves have changed
because you can
like it's very you could see the pixels
no problem um
and uh but like you know there's sort of
like that's
that's as much as you could do with a
phone really
um whereas with life like we've got this
little guy that's moving what the heck
i wouldn't even thought that was alive
but it's moving
cochlear podium it's a it's an amoeba
with scales but i can actually
feel maybe i can try to do something
here but i'm so afraid that i'm gonna
lose the live stream
okay don't cause a problem i'll keep
talking uh
yeah uh and so so uh yeah so
you know part of oh yeah part of what
um i have been feeling is like this is
i feel like a much bigger community of
telescope nerds than of microscope nerds
and i don't want to rag on astronomy
because there's lots of cool stuff you
can do with astronomy
but you're mostly looking at dots you
might
you might you might be looking at fuzzy
circles
or the moon that's pretty much it like
you got fuzzy circles dots in the moon
and some of those dots are really
interesting and you can do amazing stuff
and like backyard astronomers
for example a backyard astronomer
noticed the second
ever interstellar visitor that we have
ever documented in our solar system
it's a comet piece that is probably
ejected from an early solar system
uh many many light years away
from us uh or at least some light years
away from us
and that's freaking cool now like so i'm
not trying to take anything away from
telescope people but there aren't enough
microscope people
and i just i'm like there's more to see
you know and like i think there are a
lot of completely undocumented
things in them in the microcosm that
like
amateurs could be finding and seeing if
there were more people who were
enthusiastic about that like the more
like sort of hobbyist community
what are those little dots little dots
are the
they are bacteria oh so the one on the
um like just about the amoeba right
okay yeah yeah that's they're just
bacteria and
they're kind of forming a colony there
is this amoeba gonna hunt some of those
bacteria
it's eating on the way when when it just
crosses like while it's floating over
yeah
amazing um super cool
uh so like things like that um so
so that's that was the the thing it was
like uh
you know james very early on was like
could we make our own microscope i have
ideas about how to do this and
uh you know make it with content
creation and sharing in mind
which is like hey it's right why
not of that um and uh
and but also in the future we we will
know what microscope everyone has
so we will know how to make extra stuff
for it like if you want to do a new
eyepiece
that has a wider field of view if we
want to
do new filters we know what exactly what
filter tray it uses
if we want to um if we want to
do i don't know um different kinds of
objectives like we know
exactly how to how to do that um and we
we know what everyone has
we can trouble like people can
troubleshoot it among the community more
easily because
one of the things i've learned in having
a microscope is that like
it's not uh like there's a lot of like
procedures for
obviously like the basics but after that
there's a lot of like
opportunity for like messing about and
trying out different things and
uh and like what uh
you know almost kind of like maker type
stuff like james was telling me early on
he was like
yeah and my first like uh
you know filters i made myself out of
cardboard
you know so yeah there's
there's lots there's lots that can be
done and i i like the idea of
a lot of people sort of having the same
thing to start with so that like
i know where you're at but you also know
where each other are at and
there can be a community that's uh
that's like
communicating about how to do something
different or more interesting
um but the hardest part
for me uh and i i probably should have
expected this but of course didn't
is like james the sample you've been
showing us right now
has so many different things in it and
my samples are always like
much less diverse um and or i'm like
finding less or like and i always let my
slides dry up before
like anything interesting can come out
and so there's lots that i've learned
from
just doing the proof reading on the the
field guide that were
uh and the microscop uh instructions
that we're putting together for this
um but yeah that's that's the thing i
didn't anticipate that taking care of
your microbes is
is a skill in itself yeah yeah
and it's like i have an uh nice story
about this because like um i think
you once got a sample from a frozen
lake and then you found you know many
centers and stuff
so hank was telling me that you have no
idea
how diverse this temple is and then like
i didn't say anything but then he was
like maybe you moment
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i think it turns out it turns
out he does
um it's him yeah yeah
and then you saw something and you were
like oh no and i was like what and
you're like that's gonna eat everything
it's like a cocoapod or something like
some little like
he was like i hate when those things are
in my samples that's gonna eat all your
stenters and i'm like oh
oh no and indeed they are all gone i may
have just killed them
but maybe the shrimpy guys killed them i
can't i couldn't tell you
i i found that a helpful analogy when
talking about microscopy because i have
people come to me as the producer and
like ask me about james's work and all
this stuff it's like i knew nothing
about microscopy before we started this
channel so everything
i know about it i've learned from
working on the channel and working with
james
and the one of the closest things i
could tie it to
when people are like i just got i bought
a microscope and i don't know how to use
it or i feel like
my stuff doesn't look as good as james's
stuff and it's like sure for me
a microscope is like a guitar like it's
a thing you have to
practice with it's a thing you can get
better at it's not a thing that you can
just like watch a youtube how-to video
and immediately expect
to be the best at it like you're not
gonna buy a guitar
listen to a jimi hendrix song and know
how to play jimi hendrix song
like you have to practice and learn
these things and i think we talked
earlier about how james spends 12 hours
a day sometimes
at his at his microscope and then goes
and reads books about microscopy as well
so it takes
a lot wow guys we've documented
something
probably never reported from europe what
is that
um this is a common microorganisms
called
uh sipirostomum but this species with
endosymbiotic algae
it was never like oh my god sorry
that's really cool science is happening
live and in
in the moment right now yeah somebody
actually asked a question about like
do does james ever make any like
discoveries while doing this work or is
it just like senate the same
stuff that and i think this is one of
those times where you just saw it
happening
discoveries can be made yeah it happens
sometimes
where'd it go um sorry i um
i you can focus on that yeah
oh there
he looks like one of those um it looks
like one of those glow sticks that like
you kind of like snap and then it like
lights up
yeah i thought the boogie i thought
doctor divoki chocovardi would maybe
this is how the scripts come together
first a very very
random comparison you reverse engineer
it so you write glow stick in the middle
of the paper and you're like yeah all
right
what's coming before and after it glows
lipstick so james can you tell me any
more about what this thing is
um this is a giant single cell organism
called spirostome okay
and it's it's one of the fastest moving
organisms because um
it has this reflex or i don't know how
to call it but
it contracts and when it contracts like
it
it travels like such a distance
compared to its size it's it makes it
one of the fastest organisms
and they are common you find them
almost in every sediment sample but not
with symbiotic algae this green thing
inside
is the tiny algae just hitchhiking the
spirit and it's just like
using the sunlight you know it's doing
photosynthesis
and sharing some of the food with the
with the spirostomum and
in exchange the spiro stone is just
protecting them you know because they're
tiny and
the spirit stone is a giant so right
yeah and it's also yeah it's making
making sugars
in there that maybe this beer can use
yeah and it's like you can see them
better
now and say for anyone i see people
uh guessing like this is a uh
spherostone
is s-p-i-r-o-s-t-o-m-u-m
yes for those trying to google along
thank you matthew yeah well i was also
like what is this thing
and so trying to find information about
it that is a lot of cilia
jeez yeah yeah and it's like it has a
really long mouth actually you want me
to get closer with uh
uh can you uh can you ask him to stop
moving so much
just like uh i can kill it for you
if
[Laughter]
that's great great live stream content
how does james
get his great footage murder
it's got sort of a helical structure to
them too it looks like there's kind of a
spin
yeah when i tap the slide can you see
how it contracts
yes we can right i've seen it several of
those controls
very fast gotta record that at 240
frames a second and see if we can
actually measure how fast it's going
because
one frame i did i did but it's still
just one frame give us any data
yeah we need a phantom camera let's work
with the slow-mo guys
i have a phantom camera up there against
the microscope
uh yeah the i mean the fastest things in
the micro cosmos would be an interesting
episode for sure
i think we would need too much light and
it would oh yeah we'd bake them with the
light
for sure yeah that would be the the
problem is for the phantom camera you
need
so much light that it would just roast
everything on the slide
um i did want to jump in just to say uh
some people have
talked about just you know in general
how much they love the channel in the
comments which is great to see
um and i i also saw somebody bring up
rotifer merch
as an idea and i so this was this was
like sort of a mini little commercial
plug
section that i wanted to insert here in
the middle of us talking to say that we
have rotor for merch
right now i have it here we have the
brachionas pin
here it's hard to get focus because it's
just the normal webcam
um but we also still have the center
coreless pin
available that you can get um
we have coloring books boom okay i'm
ready i have all this stuff
and i'm to be fair i'm wearing the pair
of museum socks right now so i can't
really show them like
there we go uh but yeah
dftba.com search microcosmos we have
plenty of fun merch
there and then last little plug thing
before we answer some more questions
we also have a patreon page that we
mentioned at the end of the episodes but
i just want to reiterate it here
patreon.com journeymicro
if you want to support the channel uh
you can become a two dollar tier
or an eight dollar tier patron for the
two dollar tier
you get our uh monthly uncut videos
which is uh
going up later today uh which is like an
hour long video just footage
and music no hank narration it's just
you sit back
chill enjoy the the uncut footage and
then
uh with the eight dollar tier you get
your name uh in the end credits but you
also
get uh weekly uh high res wallpapers
that you put on your phone
your computer screen whatever you want
and you like the number one perk
obviously is that you're helping the
channel exist
and you're helping us be able to make
this channel
um elena is asking uh yes and thank you
to all of our patrons i'm sure that
there's a number of you in the room
right now uh elena's asking
i want to buy that microscope uh we will
eventually i
have the microscope on sale for people
beyond our kickstarter backers but you
know of course like the main
for our first our first step is to get
them uh
all done and complete for kickstarter
folks
uh i have one question about spirostoma
i want to ask
james in just a second but first i i
will say that the
uh microscope continues to be
on schedule which is great uh
kickstarters always have a
chance like at any given point for for
us to get behind and so i'm not saying
that we will definitely deliver on
schedule but right now things are
looking good
um and yeah we are finalizing the
uh the the language of our instructions
for the microscope right now which
um i basically have one last thing that
i need to do that everybody's
kind of waiting on me for uh because i'm
being a little precious about something
and i want to make sure that we get it
right
um and uh so that that will be done and
then they'll start
printing that and which of course like
the printer is different from the people
who make the microscope they have to get
it
so that they can box them together um
but james
uh you're looking at something right now
which makes me think maybe you're
uh looking this up but but did you say
that that those photosynthetic
spirostomum hadn't been seen in europe
ever
um i'm not sure about the but it's it's
on
it was on my list to report yeah
it was reported from africa and
uk from the uk and from the usa
but i'm not sure my professor is just
watching this live stream right now so
maybe she can comment
doing this probably so yeah
she's uh she's a c8 expert and
we work together and yeah like after our
chat i'm just gonna be like calling her
and i'm going to be like did you see
this did you see this what did you do
i'm going to keep our lives for as long
as i can
and you're not worried about um losing
it on the slide like you can always find
it again no no no this slide i prepared
it two days ago but
i didn't find it two days ago here and
i wonder how that happened i sometimes
add like um
a bit of water from the side because
they get
those lights get dry
i put them in humidity chamber so
this one i'm gonna remember this 78 is
on this
slide and i remember where i collected
the sample
and yeah that's it so i'm gonna i'm
gonna find more of it
but let's find it on the slide so
sometimes when i'm doing this like i'm
like i'll never find that again
do you have like a meant a bit of a
mental map of of the side
that you can like know where things are
on it
uh yeah like i have like some you know
like landscape marks i don't know how
how can i sure
you memorize the slide it's gonna get
better with practice so
that was one of the things that i
struggled with uh when i was playing
around with our
uh kickstarter one as well that like the
moment i zoomed in
or out from something i was like it's
gone it's nope
i'll see you again yeah like i found a
cool thing i zoomed in too far and now i
don't know where it went
well i guess well especially when
they're moving things
sometimes these things move very fast
yeah i'm sorry to make people nauseous
with my yeah so you're just like going
up and down and back and forth a little
bit sort of like
yeah see it's here
he found it give me a couple of seconds
there we go there we go just hanging out
just bent over a little thing
now it stopped moving for us
wait for it
[Laughter]
wow devoki
what is it like to write the scripts
which might be a little bit of an
open-ended question
but i don't know if you want to like uh
expand on that a little bit as far as
maybe the experience of writing and
researching and
uh diving into this world yeah it's a
lot of fun because
i feel like every script takes me on a
very very very different trajectory
sometimes it's very much like diving
through
these old papers that are like my my
sense of old has now become very varied
there's
old as in like within the 20th century
but like early 20th century and then
there's like
centuries old and all of those different
like i don't know
eras of microscopy have their own
different like
qualities for what kind of information
you're getting and how they're talking
about and that's really fun
um and then because we will have like
some episodes that are more species
specific
that's like you know we're really diving
sometimes like with the bacillaria
episode i remember realizing like
there's this whole paper just
documenting like a dance party that like
actual scientists had
like to mimic the bacillaria and so
there's always just like
weird little stories that you find like
that um
that are that are really fun and so i
think a lot of it is like in terms of
figuring out how a script to me is gonna
like kind of come together a lot of
times it's finding those like key
details where while you're reading it
you're like
huh that's really cool and then it's
like okay well what is it that i think
that's cool about it
um and what is it about this like if i
were talking to someone that i would get
like super excited
about and like want to dive more into
like talking about and just explaining
like
this is why this thing is really
fascinating to me um and so i think
that's
like kind of how like the scripts go
from just being about like a microbe
thing to then connecting it to
like other stuff in the world in our
experience of living in the world it's
like taking that
that initial like cool anecdote or that
cool clip and then just being like okay
why do i think it's cool
right that's that's always the big
question like
what's the coolest thing is a very
important question but why do i think
it's cool is a very important question
what is this now is there one that
doesn't have photosynthetic
yes also my professor just texted me and
she she's saying omg with a lot of
exclamation mark
oh man who could have thought it would
go this well
yeah and it's like um
this one is without the um endosymbiotic
algae and
this one is with the endosymbiotic algae
and this one is super common
but this is sorry there's a delay this
is yeah
so yeah huh
and they're right next to each other are
they definitely different species
or is one just colonized and one isn't
uh no the thing is when when this one
divides
it shares the weight let's say sorry
just a second for the video to catch up
yeah
so when this one divides it
shares half of the algae with it
through the cell division so then
um it's like paramecium bursaria this
paramecium species it's
always you know like it always
has some algae inside because
during the cell division it's just the
algae
like they're let's say there are 300
algae inside the organism and it
when it divides into two it's just like
each one
gets the half of it and then they grow
to the normal size
normal looking cell and then the algae
just keep reproducing
inside the organism and they it just
like um
yeah it looks like a sardine can after
some time you know it's
right yeah so yeah we i
shouldn't be thinking of this i i'm i'm
stuck in uh
i'm stuck in a heat in a animal frame
but like that yeah this this thing is
gonna
replicate by dividing so it whatever is
inside of it will remain inside of it
and the other one whatever is not inside
of it will remain not inside of it
um but but there wouldn't be a way for
like that
one that exists over there or
yeah that way to like suddenly to
to get colonized
um they sometimes eat algae and they
sometimes
uh acquire in the symbiotic algae as
well
but
i have to see them close up so
i've never seen algae inside this
species
right but um
i'm not sure if it happens with
spirosome but with some other single
cell organisms they can acquire
algae from the environment but it just
like um
it's like an ephemeral thing it doesn't
you know um
it doesn't just inherit it from
you know from one cell to the daughter
cell so it just
it happens and they acquire it and after
some time they
either digest it or they just
they just puke them out literally
pleasant
let people know people were joining the
chat later and don't know who we are
uh so i just wanted to head that off
again and say that we are the team
behind journey the microcosmos you don't
normally see human faces on this channel
so it's a bit of a surprise uh i am
matthew gatos
uh i am the producer and editor on the
channel
uh devoki do you want to introduce
yourself yeah i am devoki and i'm the
writer for the channel
and i'm james and i
do microscopy so he's our master of
microscopes james white
who we talk about at the end of the
episodes
and that's hank and i'm hank green
thank you thank you for coming to this
life with us
i i make the words uh
i i make the noises uh that
uh that devoki often makes uh with
letters yeah that's definitely the
easiest way to describe what we do
look i like to try
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
next april fool's there we go um i'll
figure it out
uh i did want to say uh uh
hi to uh the life and jars channel has
joined us in the chat
many many people have suggested a
collaboration between life and jars and
during the microcosmos and i
would love to make that happen in some
way so we will uh maybe try and figure
that out
um yeah but i also uh wanted to uh
jump in here and do a couple of quick
lightning round questions we're kind of
approaching
the end of the livestream we're only
going to go for another like 12 or so
minutes
um and so there's a couple fun lightning
round questions that i thought we could
all
answer uh first up somebody just said
uh if you could enlarge one of the
residents of the microcosmos which one
would you choose and why and
i think it's yeah it's very easy to look
at these things and think of them as
like
cute cuddly but i think if you enlarge
them to like dog
size they'd be terrifying
oh yeah like a rotary would just
don't get close
i do love rotifers though um it's it's
one of the they're one of the uh things
that i find most easily in my samples
so i um get excited about
about them um i don't know all ciliates
are just covered in weed whackers if
they get enlarged
i think i would want to see gastro
tricks because every time i see like i
mean i think it would be terrifying too
but like it's terrifying in a way that
terrifies me less than tardigrade like
the idea of a giant tardigrade
terrifies me somehow like that is
nightmare
but gaster tricks are nightmare in a way
that feels more familiar and i think
would also be
super cool to see
yeah i think that would be like pokemon
they'd be like pokemon
watering around if you suddenly just
have this like heliozoa floating behind
you yeah
my fiance is calling me a pokemon
catcher because like i i just keep
finding new things and adding them in my
collection you know so
yeah i think but i i would like to get a
you know like horse sized water bear so
i can
ride it around the you know
like with a sticker on it maybe
[Laughter]
like a giraffe-sized lacrimaria now and
just
like the most giraffe
apex predator yeah
uh i do want to uh address another
question that somebody asked on patreon
uh katie asked
about our recent human blood episode uh
and said would we consider featuring
other
like human skin flakes or spit or hair
um they said like they said i don't know
if there'd be a ton of microbes but who
knows
and i i will jump in first and just say
i think we've talked about all of these
ideas
the problem problem with this
is that james is our current only
footage provider
and we only want to ask so much of james
and
when we when we actually start asking
for blood sweat and tears
and sometimes a little bit of a harder
discussion than just
i know you like to film your fun
microbes but what if you cut yourself
like i'd like to examine the inside of
your mouth please
[Laughter]
so yeah i think it's something that
we're interested in
like but that i mean that was the first
microscopists were all about that man
they were like
what is this what is that you know and
like
um we i don't i don't think the uh the
lavender episode is up yet but um as a
as a preview lavan hook once um
sampled his own uh poop and
found something in it that was alive uh
and through his descriptions of it we
can we can confirm that he had
at that time giardia which is a you know
a disease that is caused by drinking
dirty water and having microorganisms
inside of you uh so that's wild
uh that we know that about a guy who was
11 the 1600s
yep yeah he also wrote descriptions of
his poop
good notes when you're when you're doing
your experiments yeah
but there's also there's also an element
of that of like
uh we can let lavan hook handle some of
that and
yeah it's been done yeah yeah we
we only like want the audience to be
able to get to know james
so well yeah yeah um
somebody asked real quick uh there's a
question for you hank how did the name
of the show crop up
uh i have no idea why is it a question
for me was that my idea
i mean if you would want to take credit
for it somebody else would be ready for
it but my memory
was we were in a meeting you suggested
it and i said all right but is that like
the temporary title or is that the
actual final title
and it ended up being the final title
and i think it's great but at the time
it just kind of like came out as a right
title
yeah i sometimes i will do that uh and i
will be pretending
that it's just a spur of the moment and
i want to like get people's feedback
because i'm like do you think this is
and then whenever if somebody doesn't
like it i'm always very
upset but i
i mean cosmos obviously uh is
has is that is the you know sort of
early quintessential science feature
um and i you know i looked and there was
a thing called
microcosmos that came out a while back
that was sort of like cosmos style but
it was about
just small animals like bugs and stuff
so not as micro as we are
and um and i was like well we can't just
call it microcosmos though we did get
the youtube channel which was nice
um because i felt like that was already
a thing a little bit
and i don't know i guess it just like
seemed like
i i like the idea of journey i like the
idea of like
going to a place that is here
um but that we don't go to very often
um yeah that's probably it
but you know it and with with anything
after three years pass i forget ab
that's that's the statute of memory for
me i just
don't hold on to things longer than that
i mean i think early on
one of the names was just like the germ
house
or germ show yeah yeah it was there was
a house there was definitely the word
house was involved
with that you know yeah
that was yeah that's the original hang
green voice
hello everybody welcome hello and
welcome to the germ house
i'm the rose 10 green look at this
little guy wow
he's got he's digesting stuff and maybe
he's gonna try and
oh what's that is that a rotifer no it's
a tardigrade
no it's a river no it's a rotifer it's a
router fur
uh i do uh we only have five minutes
left here uh
i thought it'd be fun to announce a
secret thing that we haven't talked
about yet
that people will find out on monday uh
when the new video goes up
uh but we were talking about what we do
on this channel what all of us do
and that is slightly getting a little
tweak to one of us
on monday because devoki is becoming
another host on journey to the
microcosmos
so very excited to do my
my close to the microphone voice
yeah so yeah obviously we'll talk about
this in monday's video a bit more
but uh hank will still be hosting the
majority of episodes but from time to
time you will hear devoki
on the channel as well yeah it's uh it's
part of my strategy
to not have everything break if i die
that's a solid strategy i'm glad to know
that i'm part of that plan
devoki you're a bigger part than you
know i have all kinds of
you basically just step in and take over
everything
so sometimes i i like to call my job
fake hank sometimes
um
snap added to my description yep
yeah uh yeah i mean it's sometimes i
feel like fake deboki where i'm like
here i am saying all the words that
someone else wrote
um gosh you found a nice little spot
james with all these little fun guys
yeah this is
this is a different slide i i switched
the slides and
uh this is also a sphero stoma wait a
second sorry
that's okay i'm like no it's not
looks like those like fruit jell-o pies
are like those
50s jello kind of like
weird things just wants to eat that
microcosm that's all
i'm hungry
okay this these ones seem smaller to me
yeah they're much smaller
because they're different species okay
so we saw
three different species of spirostomum
today
they're very pretty though yeah
i like those striations yeah
[Music]
and oh we have
this one
there's so much how do you keep them so
happy james
what do you feed these guys i read to
them you know every night
no it's just like they're in humidity
chamber so they just
the slide the slides they
don't dry up and
these things keep reproducing do you put
any do you put any like milk or
hay in there or no it's light because
then it goes really
like it loses all the oxygen super fast
so this is just one drop of sediment
and yeah and everything's alive
here and how like how long till they
like work through all of the
nutrients there uh i have one slide
i don't know where is that one right now
but it's
alive over a year now wow
there's just a lot of there's a lot of
food there's a lot of
like it that this sort of uh cascade
from living to not living anymore
there's a lot of opportunity to
capitalize on that
yeah it's like a close ecosystem you
know like everything is just living
they're dying other things eating them
and they're producing
so and they never know that we were
watching them
yeah there's been many many a comment on
the channel before of like
what if were just the microbes being
observed from above
by even larger things that are watching
and then somebody's watching them yeah i
mean this is this is the vibe we're
going for
yeah it's all the way down yeah the
pepper going forward
is it at some point you're like whoa the
word microbe is wild
[Laughter]
uh cool well we uh need to actually
sadly wrap
up here yeah coming to the end of the
live stream here
uh but as always if you're watching this
and are not already subscribed to the
channel
please do that uh if you want to check
out our patreon to help this
channel keep existing it's patreon.com
journey to micro
if you want to check out any of our cool
merch like paramecium socks or coloring
books it's all at dftba.com
i think that's all the plugs i have so
yeah if anybody else has anything final
thoughts to share
real quick before we get off oh it's
very exciting to have 500 000
subscribers
if there's anybody in your life who
you're thinking hey
they they'd probably like this let them
know about it because
um you know it's hard out here for a
youtube microscopy channel sometimes
but uh but i think that we that we found
a really cool thing to be spending some
time on
and yeah word of mouth is number one
thing like
share share with your pals people often
will say that the
the very common youtube comment of like
why don't you guys have five million
subscribers
and it's like well if you want to help
us get closer tell your mom
yeah if each one of you had got us 10
more subscribers
tell all your moms tell all your moms
every mom that you've ever focused
mother's day merch now we better hurry
well we missed our april fool's
opportunity with journey to the
microcosms
we're rebranding it's just for moms now
oh all right well yeah thank you
thank you uh to all to the three of you
for joining
um and everybody else for coming and and
hanging out
and uh and all thank you also to all 500
000 of our subscribers it's pretty
amazing very exciting
and good and goodbye we should just go
goodbye
yeah bye-bye thank you thank you
bye bye